My name's Sal Khan.
I'm the founder and faculty
of the Khan Academy,
and it's most known for a
library of 2,000 plus videos
on everything from
basic addition
all the way up to calculus
and biology and chemistry.
But what we're
really trying to do
is build a free, not for
profit virtual school
that anybody can go.
There are the videos, but
there's also software.
They can start at
basic concepts and then
just keep moving up until
they know calculus and physics
and whatever else.
The details have yet
to be worked out.
But what we're
building-- we talk
that it's a virtual
school, but we actually
do see it as kind
of the operating
system for the
school of the future,
and we're starting
trials already.
And the model we're
experimenting with--
and it seems to be
working-- is you
use the self-paced software.
You use the video.
You use the technology
for every student
to work at their own pace.
So literally you have a class
of-- you could have 30 students
or 50 students or
however many students,
and they actually don't all
have to be the same age.
Preferably they're
all of different ages,
all of different skill levels.
And they use something
like the Khan Academy.
They all work at their own pace.
And the teacher now doesn't
have to give lectures,
doesn't have to grade
homework, doesn't
have to do anything other
than-- they have a real time
dashboard.
We actually have this already,
but they have a real time
dashboard where they see
where every student is,
working at their own pace.
And it just highlights
the kids that are stuck.
Not the kids that are behind or
the kids that are ahead, just
the kids that are stuck.
They've already done 100
computer-generated exercises.
Most students who've done
100 exercises have moved on.
This student hasn't.
And the model is-- as a
first point of intervention,
actually, the teacher
or even the software
can say, why don't you pair
up those two students who
are stuck on negative
numbers, why don't you
pair them up with Susie who's
already gotten through that
and have her teach them.
And then you have this
whole peer to peer,
when you actually teach
something you learn it better
and scales up the whole-- it
makes it a social experience.
But if that doesn't work or
if Susie's not available,
then the teacher goes there.
And the teacher does a very
focused, one on one or one
on two intervention.
So it changes the model.
So every minute of a teacher's
time is actually very focused.
But because it's
very-- you don't
want kids spending the whole
day on a computer just clicking
on problems.
So I'd see you spend
maybe two hours a day
doing that, to get your
core kind of knowledge
out of the way.
You do that, you're going
to do well on the SAT.
You're going to
pass the AP test.
You're going to know how
to grammatically write
a sentence, all of the rest.
But what it does is it frees
up the rest of the day so you
can actually do actual
creative projects.
I mean, there's a lot of talk
about project-based learning.
But very little of
it is actual, real,
kind of liberated
creative stuff.
Yeah.
I see the school of
the future, big school
room, every kid working at
their own pace, a lot of time
freed up.
And the teacher's now a
coach, and a lot of time
freed up for kids to
really be creative.